c'est seul portrait des demandes
goncourt que ça va attribuer lundi
prochain le 76e prix goncourt
traditionnellement cela a lieu le
troisième lundi 2 novembre
j'ai très peur d'où c'est vous qui
servit les bons cours de 10 et 20 ans et
comment se compose la table bien voulu
couper la place du président monsieur
hervé bazin ce normal à sa droite il est
malade mallet joris la vice présidente
ensuite monsieur tournier monsieur
robles monsieur salacrou monsieur la
newsletter général
oui monsieur nourricier monsieur style
monsieur cayrol et monsieur sabbatique
venture johnson changé mais chacun à sa
place elle est immuable le vote des
goncourt signifie pour un auteur le
succès et la gloire tirage moyen du prix
au moins cent cinquante mille
exemplaires on comprend que les éditeurs
se battent pour obtenir un tel prix
faisons quelques statistiques en vingt
ans sur 28 concours neuf sont revenus à
gallimard 3 à grasset 3 au seuil case
prix sur 20 pour celles que l'on appelle
le trio infernal des limargue grasset le
seuil pour bernard clavel l'ancien
académicien ce quasi monopole est le
fait des jurés
c'est une chose qu'on peut lire tous les
ans dans les journaux qu'on entend à
toutes les radios et on a l'impression
de découvrir aujourd'hui une vérité moi
c'est une vérité que je connaissais
avant d'entrer à l'académie goncourt
j'ai pensé j'ai espéré que peut-être on
pouvait arriver y remédier j'ai vu que
ça n'était pas possible mais je ne pense
pas que qui que ce soit soit acheté ou
vendu là dedans dit simplement pour des
raisons peut-être d'amitié d'affection
parce que des auteurs appartiennent à
une maison d'édition
ils votent systématiquement pour des
poulains de ces maisons d'édition et ça
c'est une chose que je n'ai pas pu
supporter c'est pourquoi j'ai quitté
l'académie goncourt
quant à un membre
jury et romancier évidemment il ya un
éditeur alors heureusement que la vesle
ne parle pas de corruption ni d'
enveloppe mais enfin il peut y avoir des
influences des affinités si on a choisi
un éditeur c'est parce que on se sent
chez soi avec lui alors on peut préférer
sa production alors le remède a slave
il est évident et il est appliqué c'est
que les jurys composent une espèce de
cocktail très divers de maisons
d'édition je peux vous dire qu'à
l'académie en cours par exemple sont
représentés six ou sept éditeurs alors
dit clavel pourquoi sont toujours les
mêmes conditions qui ont les grands prix
à écouter quels sont les même si on dit
gallimard le seuil grasset c'est un
petit peu comme si pour l'automobile on
disait peugeot renault citroën ça
représente 70% de la production
littéraire en france ce n'est pas
étonnant que ce soit cela cai très
souvent les prix pourtant cette année
les choses semblent changer on dit que
l'académie goncourt serait prêt à sortir
du trio infernal gallimard grasset le
seuil
alors lundi prochain qui le retournement
de vladimir volkoff pélagie la charrette
d'antonine maillet mauzé ou le lézard
qui pleurait dîner scania ti outils jean
l'horizon de simone schwarz bart qui la
seule chose sûre pour le moment c'est le
menu il ya le déjeuner commencé avec un
béluga de la caspienne et du gain bien
c'est du caviar et puis le foie gras des
landes en lob à la gelée
ensuite le marbrier drouot qui sera
suivie d'une gigue de chevreuil
saint-cuthbert crème de marron le
fromage et puis le décès à ce sera un
sorbet aux fruits de la passion avec des
mignardises sorbet aux fruits de la
passion littéraire bien sûr oui mais ce
sera à la fin du repas